and not only did they did they win they
trounced the fascist in kansas they
absolutely trounced them um i want to
welcome a great political strategist
he's going to give us years and years
and years of his knowledge of what
happened
yesterday what this means not just for
for the democratic party but for
democracy because i think that is so
important and i think this political
strategist
brings that knowledge to us that it's
not just important for a political party
i've talked to him so many times on air
during the january 6 select i am i'm so
happy to have him back i haven't had a
chance yet we've been so busy i haven't
had a chance to thank him yet for
joining us on all those january 6
select hearings so i'd like to do it now
and i want to welcome
david bender david how are you
well i'm good and and
you're very welcome but you know i
charge per year do you years and years
and years of experience oh okay okay
well we're here so i you know you'll get
my bill absolutely yeah send it over
send it over
actually you know
at a certain point we have a cap on it
it's a
when you get to decades
i do want to say first of all you're
welcome i i've been listening to the
show
this morning and and i think you're spot
on what has happened david david i'm
always spot on
i'm always fun
i'll call it the sweet spot
and and the sweet spot here is sweet for
a lot of people
who saw this
and i i'm
pleased to say i i was one of them this
was not a
i know that the polls
showed and let's let's agree now tony
that polls are insane in in the year in
which we live because we're not
polling people who actually vote we're
polling i i don't even know who answers
polls anymore and i know that there are
some people particularly uh the trumpist
uh or should call them the
fascist
cheeto dust people
these people
refuse to play along in fact they
mislead in what they're going to do so
let's i i think we've been pulling too
much for years
and the polls that showed that kansas
would be
close and possibly go the other way
had no clue
about how people were really motivated
and feeling in a way
that i think we saw the results
yesterday
the the number of voters exceeded the
2020 primary
a presidential year in an off year
uh in august i mean come on
people are deeply motivated when you
take away
something from them
and this is what the republicans
continually fail to understand
they were going to take away
obamacare because you know in 2010
everyone hated obamacare before they
knew what it was and they won big
victories campaigning against it they
thought oh we'll keep doing that
but they were fighting the old war not
realizing that once people had it
and they liked it
you take it away from them
and they're
pissed off
now this is even
as significant as health care is
this is going to the lives and literally
the lives of women all across america no
matter their political party
and and what i found astounding last
night and i you know i have a great
regard for steve kornacki at msnbc i
think he's great with numbers
but he missed something which is unusual
for him but he missed it big time
he was talking about the biden vote in
counties and comparing that to the no
vote in kansas on the novo being keeping
abortion
and he was comparing apples to oranges
this wasn't a democrat republican issue
right this was a human issue
and
the only thing now and the big question
with what is it 98 days left to the
november election
and and less than that to when people
start voting in october
is we've got to hang this around the
republicans next
every candidate for every office at
every level but particularly the us
house and senate
have to defend the supreme court and
have to defend their long record of
saying they want to take away a woman's
right to choose
because they've won that
for a while
and if they want to campaign on that in
november
good luck to them in
dark red districts like kansas good luck
to those republicans who have to run on
their record now if the democrats are
not a circular firing squad if the
democrats figure out a way
to aim at the republicans and not one
another
this is a target that is so fat
and so obvious
and you just shoot them with their own
ammunition they've given us that weapon
years and years 40 years of we're gonna
do this thing
okay as you said they caught the car
they should choke on the exhaust pipe
right well the wheel is on top of them
for sure i want to bring in my co-host
and uh a friend of ours gabe sanchez hey
gabe hey morning good morning good
morning so um i want to talk about
yesterday because yesterday was big
victories there was more than just the
midterms
yesterday we watched as the senate
pulled the pacnack over the line um we
this morning opec is announcing that
they're going to up production um which
is another win for this administration
but by them saying yes we're going to up
production to make sure the gas costs uh
keep going in the correct direction
which is downward they're so many so
many successes here that the
pro-democracy party are delivering to
american people and i think you're right
that they are noticing it's this this
this this polling where um joe biden has
a a a bad approval rating let me tell
you something the polls are wrong but
not only are they wrong
people aren't making their decisions
based on joe biden being the president
because joe biden is not threatening joe
biden is not threatening their rights
it's the republicans it's it's the kerry
lakes
it's it's the the the eric schmitz it's
it's these people in in michigan it is
herschel walker it is dr oz it is jd
vance it is ron desantis
these republicans like greg abbott and
some of these others are the ones who
are coming after your way of life but
just in the last 48 hours we've had so
many successes that are proving and i
believe and i said it this morning
that this idea of pro-democracy is now
starting to bake in the cake which is
super important and that is why we have
to keep pushing and pushing and pushing
and lean into politicizing these issues
i so many times um we get comments me
and gabe and i know david you probably
have heard this too democrats aren't
tough enough democrats don't fight hard
enough the messaging is horrible over
and over and over again
the one thing that democrats are
learning very quickly
and the select committee has kind of
taught them this and i don't know if liz
cheney knows this or not but i think she
kind of rubbed off on him a bit yeah
we are starting to politicize these
issues and we are winning by knowing
that politicizing them creates
engagement and engagement in the
democracy gets a result that gets closer
to equality and equity
i i i defer to gabe
yeah i think well i even think that some
of these issues like you know gas prices
and things like that we've got 19 states
that are below four dollars 15 states
that are below 389 like we're finding
that these issues that republicans have
made such a big deal about
are are not issues anymore and i
wouldn't be surprised that in the next
month that doesn't even become a talking
point anymore because it's not really
that important in the grand scheme in
the grand scheme you have to deal with
these people that you've identified as
these pro-fascist leaders or want to be
dictators that are attempting to rule
and reign over the people and take
rights away so i think for these other
things that they've made such a big deal
about like oh you know putting a sticker
on a gas pump saying i did that right
well it turns out those things have
actually backfired and it actually is
biden pointing at the gas price going
down i dropped it i dropped it i did
that the price is going down because of
me so you see these things that are
actual non-issues and i think again
probably the next month or so they won't
even be a talking point because
republicans will have dropped them
democrats will say we can mention it but
that's not the bigger problem that's at
stake right now so i think
um i think a lot of i mean i don't know
what other small things they're going to
complain about other than just
projecting but none of us can know and
that's
listen i have been doing this as we know
since grover cleveland second term not
fluid
where's my paw gone to the white house
ha ha ha
anyone anyway so
i'm sorry i don't remember that but
let's pretend i do here's here's what i
do want to say
we don't know gabe you're right we don't
know what the issues are going to be and
one of the things that i always
really chuckle at sometimes get annoyed
by
is the phrase if the election were held
today
because when someone says that
number one
they've never done a campaign
and number two
it never is because they're saying if it
were
when now we have october is an entire
voting month fewer states less
you know early voting but still october
is when voting starts
so it's
you know not one day but if if by the
end of september
we have a sense of what the american
people are focused on and what things
are driving people's
interest in wanting to vote
the end of september is going to be the
measurement and that is two months away
from now we've got some time and a lot
of things can change they always do
that's the one thing you can count on is
the unexpected
but let's look at what happened you just
ticked off a few of them let's mention
that uh alswahari has been taken out
that is an incredible victory that this
democratic president this so-called weak
on terrorism he abandoned afghanistan
well he took out the guy who was the
greatest threat and killed tens of
thousands of americans and and people
around the world civilians over
20 years 30 years of of running free of
30 years of this
this is
a huge victory that we all
should say
made this country safer because joe
biden was the president but you're right
it's not going to be about your budget
it shouldn't be it should be about each
of those this election should be
nationalized
but in each of those races you ticked
off tony in in uh you know with with the
the governor of michigan with the
governor of florida they should all be
forced to take positions
about their national views uh and and
they are views that are
anti-democratic
they are views that are anti-women
they're anti-environment
they're pro-gun
these are all
absolutely each one alone is devastating
and guess what september the month i
just talked about
this committee with liz cheney showing
you know democrats how to be strong
the committee will be meeting again
on primetime television in september
so
hey i'm looking forward to the new
season i can't wait to have you on for
the new season
any anytime anywhere you know
it is uh
listen this has been
one of the most
gratifying things i've gotten to work on
in my entire career was helping to work
with the groups that
organized and it was a coalition of
everybody it was 150 pro-democracy
groups indivisible and common cause
all these great groups coming together
to build attention we started work
months and ahead months ahead of
the first hearing june 9th
and you know i came on with you we
talked about this we had to build
awareness everyone said no one's going
to pay attention
it's a loser no ratings nothing's going
to happen
well when we started this
at the beginning of june public opinion
was about split on whether trump was
accountable and whether this was
important to look at and make any
difference and it was yesterday's news
it's now at two-thirds and growing right
it's gonna break 70 percent and those
are numbers that no one can ignore
it's like the republicans finally
figured out they couldn't ignore the
veterans and had to turn their votes
around after the fist bump
on
trying to kill veterans benefits i want
that fist bump i'm sure you've got the
clip it should be over and over and over
yeah i i've got i've we've got we've got
any clip that you would want we got a
great executive producer here that can
i know
that can spit up any kind of clip that
you absolutely uh he just goes on
twitter
slow motion is always fun
i'll tell you speaking of clips and
speaking of the january six select
committee because i actually appreciate
the the talk about the organization
because i think that is the difference
last night because adam kinzinger he is
on the select committee and i am
grateful for what adam kinzinger is
doing for the select committee but this
morning he's on cnn both siding things
and the reason why is because a a a
representative a sitting incumbent a
republican peter meyer who voted against
or for impeaching trump lost last night
because democrats said hey if we're
going to play for democracy we better
play for the entire game and i think i
think
when you're upset when when you get adam
kinzinger upset in this in this way and
in this moment you know we're doing
something right and the organization is
intense i'm gonna i'm gonna have to
respectfully not disagree but sure
yellow light a flashing yellow light up
yeah absolutely
because playing with fire
can sometimes
burn you and go the wrong way mm-hmm
if gibbs the guy who
wound up the trumpist who wound up
winning that nomination winds up
winning the election
we've got another election denier in the
house
and now
in fairness the the strategy has shown
that the democrat is likely to beat this
extremist in a moderate you know this is
grand rapids this is charles ford's old
district i i i get the strategy i do
but
i i do think and a lot of
smart
people who i respect
who are not adam kinser they're not
republicans who are trying to both sides
it are saying
if you support a pro-autocracy person
even in the cause of trying to win the
seat
you're taking a risk and that's why
flashing yellow
because if some of these people squeak
through because we played this game
that's very risky now the flip side is
tony in your own missouri
because
last night uh the candidate uh famous
family named bush
uh
uh she she spent a lot of money from
from the
anheuser-busch exactly
the usch not the
right right not the other bush the
original bush the original one not what
was once called the bush crime family
and and their crimes were like you know
jaywalking compared
but the this anaheiser bush candidate uh
her full name is what what's her she's
uh um
well that's the thing is is that her
name is is what is got her the attention
in saint louis and really when you look
at the vote
yeah when you look at the vote um trudy
bush valentine yeah
valentine thank you um um i'll i'll be
full disclosure i voted for lucas koontz
because i i actually felt like that
lucas koontz could beat either eric
schmidt eric greitens or vicky hartzler
which were polling at the top now eric
greitens was actually pulling above
vicki hartzler but when the vote came
down he lost big time i mean he lost big
time and and
we we watched last night in the state of
missouri that this rhino talk
is not is not playing well it's not a
it's this trumpism rhino we're going to
kill rhino thing is not playing well no
even in even in missouri now
i will i will as a trumpet right
well i mean
eric schmidt he's a scumbag and the
reason why i say that is because of this
he has spent taxpayers dollars on the
state side the state taxpayers dollars
that our money
suing school districts for the last two
years since the pandemic not only just
to choose what their choice was as far
as how they were going to keep their
staff and their students safe whether it
be mask or distancing or other measures
that they were taking because of the
pandemic but he started to sue school
districts based on surveys that they
were doing which all schools do surveys
they want to know they want to know what
their districts the makeup of their
districts are they want to know what the
feelings are a lot of districts were
actually because missouri um a lot of
people during the pandemic moved out of
the city into the more rural areas they
they had to reconstruct some of their
school district so they were doing
surveys based on that these surveys had
nothing to do with political views or
crt or any of this nonsense but eric
schmidt was using state taxpayer dollars
to sue local school districts which was
costing local people who pay taxes to
that school district money so he was
double dipping and the reason why is to
make sure that he ran a campaign against
the rhino killer
eric greitens he wanted to get the
attention it was all about the attention
to be in the news where did he stand
when you asked him the question who's
president of the united states
well
and that's and that is important with
eric schmidt i think um the importance
there is that eric schmidt was one of
the first attorney generals that joined
texas in their stupid little lawsuit for
the coup d'etat in pennsylvania you
remember before january 6 17 attorneys
general right that's right and he was
one of the first one to jump on board as
soon as ken paxton that criminal down in
texas decided to sue pennsylvania and
michigan and i think arizona and one
other state i believe there's four or
five states that that ken paxton sued
and eric schmidt jumped right on the
bandwagon of the coup d'etat he wanted
to overthrow the the country's vote he
wanted to overcome as he backed off my
question is if you ask him today
we know what carrie lake says what what
does he say about
was the election of fraud is he still
saying the same thing today well i think
i think it's a good question to ask him
and the journalists and democrats should
really pressure him and i hope bush
valentine does pressure him and not only
pressures him on who is the president of
the united states which is a simple
answer it's a simple easy answer for
anyone for anyone who believes in
democracy but also the question of where
eric schmidt stands on making sure that
women have access absolutely access to
healthcare and that's why women
candidates this year and this i was for
lucas as well in the full disclosure you
know that i i right one candidate i i've
already sent a text this morning
encouraging his people not to be
disheartened they run a great race
way underfunded compared to her she
could write big checks i hope he stays
running all this 39 years old i hope he
keeps running this
iraq and afghanistan veteran who's a
great candidate and stays right on the
ground running
against josh hawley in two years that's
he he's absolutely great democratic
nominee what a great idea just holding
that momentum you know i hope i hope he
doesn't
come away from this feeling
disheartening he's acquitted himself
very well and ran a much closer race
than those polls showed that he would
but but to to the point of trudy bush
valentine
a woman on the ballot in november
any woman candidate other than carrie
lake and and some of these you know mega
women who are anti-choice
those the women candidates that we're
going to field are going to be stronger
by definition because they can look at a
man they can look at eric schmidt and
say
how dare you
how
dare you say i don't have those rights
and that's a very powerful argument
more women candidates who are running
for house
and senate the better off we are now in
your state again in missouri
there's there is
a rhino there's john wood
the that john dempsey put in who was
polling it about a lot again polls let's
not say we believe them but it would be
about ten percent
and if that turns out to be true you get
seven percent
peels off some of that uh middle ground
and it's all going to come out of uh
schmidt
uh
that's an opportunity for trudy bush
valentine to win that senate race i
still don't think this is
oh absolutely
last night it's not over at all no i
think i think i think you're correct
when you're talking about trudy bush
valentine
if if i were her political strategist
which you know this better than i do i
just yell and scream into a microphone
but if i were her political strategist i
would say i would say trudy there's two
things that you should do two things
is you should find those lucas koontz
voters in those real trump areas and you
should lean into this pink movement
absolutely lean into the pink movement
and if i had advice for lucas goons i
would say don't stop running just like
you would but i would say be out there
pounding the drum right that
in those areas in those areas because he
if you look at the the ideas last night
running he ran strong in the rural areas
he did he he ran really strong in those
trump areas which is really important
and is going to be really important for
bush valentine so if they can band
together and create a team here where
they're trying to campaign for democracy
for democracy i think not only can lucas
coons help bush valentine win that win
that seat but he can also set himself up
for a great run against against uh josh
holland i mean josh hawley
well the other thing too is i think
that's that's really important is is by
by continuing to stay involved and not
just back away from the spotlight and
say okay
i'll come back in a few years or
whatever he will continue to make
himself a name right he will he will be
on he will be on the front lines to say
i was there i was helping i was you know
defending i was doing all these things
so that isn't just like oh he was a
nobody who ran and now he's trying to do
it again for a different seat or
whatever it might be but actually is
there
front and center on the national stage
you'd be like this is where i was and i
didn't back down
to your point one of the things that i
think is really interesting about texas
texas is so
jerry-rigged now even i knew he was
going to think of beto i knew he was
going to be able to i had to think of
better because
veto has run now for this will be his
third bid for office other than his
house seat
and you know the presidential race
didn't go very well for him
uh the senate race was very close
one of the best senate races anyone can
imagine and again because the system in
texas is so jury raped against a
democrat state
and it's going to be worse now with
voter suppression
but greg abbott has been so terrible
and so many things on his watch
the power grid failing uvaldi uh el paso
and who has been on the ground
there in each process who's been doing
what the governor should be doing going
there and hearing food to people yeah
actually showing up to the funeral
holding up for the funerals and being
present
that's what veto is so i you know
i'm not even ruling that out in a year
like this and beto has done it exactly
right he said with courage he's done it
with confronting
you've watched him walk into that room
uh rabbit sitting there and say this is
on you you're responsible
uh you know that that took
cojones as they say
and let's hope that you know a lot of
people recognize who beto is but i i i
just want to say
there i come back to missouri because
there was great president from missouri
uh from independence where lucas
now wolves
uh a guy named harry truman uh you all
remember him i know you know i i i i
know i met him i shook his hand i've
taken a lot of pictures with him
actually i know i it well listen i gave
him a start in politics
[Laughter]
i used to buy hats from him back before
he went out of business
but here's the thing about harry truman
he he
you know his nickname was give him hell
herod
and
he said
uh i'm not giving the republicans hell
i'm just telling
them the truth and they think it's hell
right and that
is what democrats need to do
in september october november they need
to tell the truth about republicans and
they're going to feel like they're in
hell right because
they put themselves there they are now
they've they've gone to the dark side
with
orange satan
and that
is going to come back they all have to
defend that right we make them defend
all of those things
anti-democracy anti-women pro-gun
uh anti-environment you name it they're
on the wrong side of it well hell you
had rand paul on the floor yesterday
before the pact passed talking about how
asthma is some kind of trivial thing and
it's not really service connected and
all this nonsense and he just he just
demeaning veterans even more giving more
fodder for us to politicize because
again i keep saying this over and over
everyone democrats have always been so
scared to politicize stuff but it seems
like it's turning and and i want to show
you proof of that which is this better
video speaking of beto this is a trump
voter
and listen to what he says about the
republican party
and beto aurora and why it is so
important that we make sure to
politicize these issues just the issues
like you were talking about not just
like the power grid for for greg abbott
but guns abortion women's rights in
texas i mean all these extreme views
that greg abbott has adopted because he
has to you know the tail is wagging the
dog but listen to this voter here that
they captured and why he's supporting
vetto i've been a lifelong republican
voter actually voted for donald trump
absolutely 100 veto supporter um
he's very intelligent he has well
thought out you know approaches and you
spend a little time listening to him
take a little time and listen to what
his has to say about these different
issues because
it's not right or left it's about texas
and that's what we need to hear we don't
hear that
it just seemed to get progressively and
progressively far more extreme far away
from the republican party that i
remember you know as a younger person so
i really had to take a hard look at
myself take a hard look at what i
believed and
what i supported and i just found myself
a position where i
could not support that side of the aisle
anymore absolutely a lifelong republican
voter and uh i am voting for beto award
for governor state of texas boom and i
think i think he's paid for by you know
beto uh is that a spot that's running uh
uh beto actually posted that on on
twitter um but this is a gentleman who
is a lifelong republican has and and
these exist
right in the landscape and i think david
that it is so important that people
remember we have not had a national
election we as a nation have not told
the republican party yet what we think
about january 6. and in the meantime in
the meantime they lied and gaslighted us
about gas and about all about the the
war in ukraine they've been gaslighting
us about women's rights and roe and on
and on and on it goes and i think
they've had a miscalculation here and
just as i said in the beginning
i think the pro-democracy part of this
election and hopefully the next two
three four five cycles that
pro-democracy part and that engagement
is starting to bake in the cake because
we've always had republican engagement
baked in the cake with their media
apparatus with their organization with
their gaslighting with their lies but
now we have taken back control as a
pro-democracy
organization in that it's just people
who believe that yes we should have a
vote yes we should have rights and we
should let the people speak we the
people are the government
we are the government
you know i so happy to hear you say that
because that is government is us
right been my mantra for since ronald
reagan started saying you know pointing
at the government saying that's the
worst thing ever that you know the thing
people fear most is i'm from the
government i'm here to help once the
government was demonized
and it became the other right in that
in 1980 and then you know for the last
40 years
people forget
we
us
everyone here we're the government
police people
teachers fire people people who work on
your roads we're the government that is
the government and and if you make it
the other if you make it some evil thing
of course people are going to be afraid
of it or need it but when you realize
what you just said we are the government
the government is us not somebody else
and we also have a responsibility to
take care of each other
by being responsible citizens it's not
just a vote you've got to be a citizen
all year long
that is
what government used to be about back
with
your friend and mine harry truman
back with fdr who i know you also
remember well
uh
who who understood that that government
could
change people's lives in the tennessee
valley authority or social security or
all of the things that government did
that we take for granted now
but
good luck trying to take that away
um so let me ask you a quick history
question you you know fdr you remember
him well do you remember he had a little
dog
he had a little of course i i remember
yeah going to the house and petting the
dog and okay
here's it you may you know it's it's
morning it's you know it's late night
election results so you're probably
fading a little bit on remembering the
dog
the picture for you
he had a little dog a little terrier dog
that i
was
a beautiful dog but the republicans then
like the republicans now got personal
and ugly
they attacked
everything about fdr they attacked his
wife they attacked him it was all
personal invective you know terrible
horrible stuff like we now see coming
out of trump's mouth but they were
pretty bad she's pretty republican and
finally finally the republicans said
something about his little dog
so fdr flipped the script and he said i
can take it
uh if they attack me that's fine but
they're even attacking my little dog
the dog's name was
fala
la and that dog became the most famous
dog in america there's a statue of that
dog right now
as big as fdr statue
and it turned around because it showed
how petty and venal
that the the uh the republicans were so
if you'll allow me a moment of
verisimilitude
um oh he's going to show us his little
dog
this
little dog fella
who i just got
oh and his name is fala named in honor
of fdr the actual full name of phallo
which i didn't know myself you think i'd
remember
was uh named after a scottish
figure from the
1400s named
murray the outlaw of phala hill
so his full name is murray the outlaw of
phala hill
but for sure
this is his first on-camera appearance
on
your show your ghost show
so fala say hi to jorge say hi
he's just saying hi to my friend jorge
and
tony and that's gabe hello hi
the audience loves the animals yeah they
love yeah yeah yeah
gabe's dogs always make a special yeah
they'll hang out in the background you
know sometimes but i think on the dog
point you know there is a especially now
on the internet there's actually a doc
called don't [ __ ] with cats it's it's a
crazy documentary on netflix but there
is a certain uh rule amongst humans
which is you do not attack
those that are weaker especially animals
right your pets your dogs your cats
whatever it might be
but as soon as you brought up the
terrier i was like
i had this image
of
uh of the wizard of oz right and the
wicked witch saying you know i'll come
after you and your little dog too right
and like that is the republican party
but when you when you start coming after
some that's that's your pet right people
love their pets you know to the ends of
the earth right yep when you go after
that that's like yeah that's that is a
that is a new low that is a low that you
should not go it's like you don't attack
kids you don't attack pets there is a
certain understood rule and as soon as
you break that rule
then you know that that group that is
coming after them is not to be trusted
and gabe to your point about the weaker
that's what trump has and trump ism has
always been about right
punching down
right hitting more vulnerable people
going after
uh people of color women uh going after
vulnerabilities going after
people with disabilities exactly
down
and of course the the metaphor is you
know the little dog but
you know what they've always done this
who they are
and if we remember
you know uh as has famously been said if
if people tell you who they are believe
them
and republicans are exactly who they say
they are we just have to remind people
of that really well well
the projection is a confession you know
earlier you said that they're they feel
like they're being attacked right or
they feel like they're in hell well it's
only because like you said it is true it
is them feeling the consequences of
their actions there is no cancel culture
they're not getting cancelled it's all
consequences right there is an equal and
opposite reaction to the action that
they took right and so
uh earlier you also mentioned about how
like the government is us and i think a
line from that video from the better
supporter it was so key and i think so
important as he says this isn't a right
or left issue this is a texas issue this
is about texas and i think at its
fundamental core
it's even more
uh more simple than that right it's not
just texas it's human right it is human
rights human human accessibility to
certain rights that we should have as
citizens of this country and so it's not
a right or a left thing these are these
are uh rights that we should have as
veterans right as women as uh same-sex
couples whatever they might be these are
rights that we should have and it's not
you know it again it's not a right or
left thing it's just being a decent
human being in caring for those who have
helped put you
into your position to represent the rest
of people but as soon as you fail them
you know they're in hell
because they're not you know they're
they all of a sudden feel like they're
the victim right and that's what
republicans do unless there's
accountability they do it again right
exactly someone
wisely said about january 6th if they
are not held accountable for it it was a
dress rehearsal
and next time they put on the show
right next time the curtain comes down
on our democracy so we have we have work
to do we have miles to go before we
sleep i'm going to feed fala here
one more thing before we go david i want
to show you what accountability looks
like this is the ape ap was in the room
wow magnificent women with these
magnificent women when that when the
vote came in and i want to do this
too
so let's watch the celebration and and
and the fascists in kansas being held
accountable here watch
[Applause]
dallas
and you see women here of all stripes
this isn't just
cookie cutter these are these are
women of color these are men that are
supporting i want to see the men exactly
and their men are not one too
it's very important but there's a great
interview coming up um that the ap did
with one of the organizers on the ground
and she talked about we have uh worked
so hard for the past year but
know last couple months
to really um you know communicate with
voters about what this was at stake and
really what was at stake was our
constitutional rights and our freedom
and so um you know a coalition of voters
across the political spectrum came
together today and voted no they voted
no to protect their neighbors
they voted no on changing the
constitution
and really
you know demonstrated our free state
routes here in kansas are alive and well
i'm super proud to be from kansas
tonight and i feel like my state just
showed up and boldly told me that they
are going to take care of me and my
female friends and everyone that can get
pregnant in the state of kansas we are
protected tonight
i implore everyone out there
go be kansas be kansas let's
beat kansas and let's show them what
democracy can do let's let me close with
that line there is nothing the matter
with kansas
not a goddess everything is right and
toto
we're going back to kansas that's great
david thank you for joining us i look
forward to this select hearing season
two i hope you join us every single one
i know you joined us before you know
what i i i don't think we're gonna have
the greatest news i hope i'm wrong uh i
don't have a lot of confidence in the
republicans of wyoming but that election
is in a couple weeks right so if you
want to talk after that let's talk after
that because
cheney i don't think liz cheney
is gonna care a wit
she is doing what she believes is right
and if the republican voters of wyoming
have lost their minds
then you know so much for it i think
she'll run a closer race than a lot of
people right but but you know it is what
it is in republican primaries now that
and and that
by the way is the great news for the
general election
because
david for joining us it was so great to
have you everyone stick around we will
be right back
right after these messages thank you
david have a great day you too